foreign
involved in a commercial Collision it
was nuts yay it all happened while the
actor was filming in New York City he's
seemingly working with legendary
director Martin Scorsese who was spotted
on set but the idea is just to work with
as many good storytellers and directors
as possible work on projects that are
challenging and inspiring at one point
Timothy walks confidently out the front
door and onto the street which is when
things didn't go as planned in the
moment captured by photographers Timothy
power walks chest first into a large
camera on a metal jib arm the actress in
the scene clearly startled by the
incident as a young actor you really put
your performance in the hands of your
scene partner Timothy on the other hand
appeared to shake it off with a big
smile and continued filming like a pro
it's kind of like what you dream about
when you want to be an actor when you're
growing up and uh
you know dive into different worlds
different circumstances
so Timothy had a little mishap on set
but his love life seems to be smooth
sailing see that's what I'm talking
about yeah earlier this week a source
confirmed to E.T Timothy is dating Kylie
Jenner but they're keeping things casual
our source adds it's not serious but
Kylie's enjoying hanging out with him
and seeing where it goes that's what it
is to uh be young quote it's been really
fun for her because it feels a lot
different than her past relationships
it's new and exciting for Kylie growing
up in front of the spotlight is
extremely difficult and you're growing
and you're making mistakes
and everyone's judging you so that's
definitely hard but there's so many
blessings that come along with the toes
[Music]